on va retrouver elena volochine sur le
terrain côté russe où vous vous trouvez
à koursk elena interrompu par le
président volodymyr zelensky tiens
puisqu'on a abordé la question de
l'arsenal ukrainien une chose certaine
c'est qu'en face les russes sont
suffisamment équipées pour pour tenir on
a vu ces chars ses blindés cette valse
s'orchestre s'opérer sans orchestré ces
dernières semaines vous l'avez
d'ailleurs largement couverts sur notre
antenne lna il ya une véritable force de
frappe russe a aujourd'hui qui est entre
en scène
oui d'après ce que me disait
effectivement ces dernières semaines les
experts militaires russes c'est toute la
force de frappe toute l'armée russe qui
a été mobilisée sur ce front ukrainien
pour encercler l'ukraine pour rentrer
aussi via le bélarus et pour et cette
opération était dûment préparé par la
mère par la mer d'azov par les airs et
donc effectivement ce cas l'ukraine
aujourd'hui en face d'elle c'est toute
l'armée de vladimir poutine alors avec
les états unis qui ont dit qu'ils ne
causent aucun prétexte ils n'apporteront
une aide militaire à l'ukraine et on le
comprend on parle là de pays qui possède
l'armé nucléaire et effectivement on a
aussi l'impression on a eu l'impression
au début que les ukrainiens avaient
peut-être décidé de céder finalement
quelque part à la force pour éviter un
bain de sang par exemple on a vu du côté
de la frontière où je me trouvais ce
matin j'étais à moins de 30 kilomètres
du côté de kharkiv la ville qui selon
certaines de mes informations je n'ai
pas pu les vérifier mais on m'a dit de
source paramilitaires que cette ville
serait encerclé je dois encore vérifier
si cela est vrai mais en tout cas ce que
c'est que ce qui semble être certain
c'est que l'armée russe a franchi la
frontière de ce côté-là et l'armée
ukrainienne n'aurait opposé aucune
résistance
souvenons nous de ce qui s'est passé en
2014 en crimée l'armée russe avait
encerclé les bases militaires il ya eu
un ultimatum et en attendaient de savoir
s'il y aurait une guerre puisque les
soldats ukrainiens eux mêmes avec
lesquels nous nous trouvions à
l'intérieur de ces bases nous disait on
attend l'ordre de notre commande à
l'époque le président ukrainien petro
porochenko avait dit sortez partez on
s'aide la crimée à vladimir poutine
c'est pour ça qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'effusion de bain de sang alors du coup
je me demandais si c'était le même
scénario qui est en train de se profiler
puisque on a l'impression que l'armée
russe
avancé assez assez rapidement et gagner
du terrain mais on viens de l'entendre
le président volodymyr zelensky a
annoncé la mobilisation a annoncé a
demandé aux hommes ukrainien de défendre
leur terre il faut savoir aussi que côté
russe il y a eu un ordre de l'état major
des armées de traiter les soldats
ukrainien avec je ne me rappelle plus du
mot employé mais c'était c'était de ne
pas maltraiter en tout cas les soldats
d'ukrainiens les soldats faits
prisonniers et aussi d'épargner les
populations civiles de porter l'armée
russe se targuer de porter d'être des
frappes très ciblée de cibler uniquement
l'infrastructure militaire alors le
scénario que je vois derrière ceux ci
c'est le fait que vladimir poutine a
pour projet d'occuper l'ukraine une fois
que l'armée ukrainienne aura été et que
l'ukraine aura été mise à nu et que
l'armée ukrainienne aura été rendue
incapable de combattre et pour occuper
un territoire qui est très largement
déjà très hostile à vladimir poutine eh
bien
il faut éviter absolument un carnage et
une catastrophe humanitaire et c'est là
ce qui semble être le but de vladimir
poutine occupé l'ukraine mais sans
effusion de sang elena effectivement des
morts ce ne serait pas bon pour vladimir
poutine demain d'autant qu'il ya déjà
des russes à moscou qui ont commencé
aussi peu nombreux soit il a manifesté
leur opposition à cette guerre alexeï
navalni depuis sa prison ce matin ainsi
eddy largement opposés ce n'était pas
vraiment surprenant il ya des dizaines
de manifestants on vient de l'apprendre
anti guerre qui ont été arrêtés à moscou
et saint pétersbourg ça va être
difficile ça leur est d'ailleurs
interdit de s'exprimer dans la rue
aujourd'hui un l'ordre formel leur a été
ni le kremlin il espère que les russes
vont soutenir un vladimir poutine que
risque-t-il de se passer côté côté russe
pour l'instant ils sont derrière le chef
du kremlin les russes
le problème côté russe et qu'on vit dans
une réalité absolument parallèle dans
cet immense pays qu'est la russie les
gens ont une histoire ont une réécriture
de l'histoire moderne qui ce qui ce qui
s'est passé depuis 2014 en fait un
depuis l'annexion de la crimée depuis le
tout début lorsque vladimir poutine
d'abord disait quand cris mais ce
n'était pas lui et puis qu'ensuite il a
obéi à un référendum populaire soit
disant de population locale qui avait
elle même qui avait résisté à l'invasion
des fascistes qui était arrivé au
pouvoir en ukraine après la révolution
de maidan fasciste nazi génocide tout ça
c'est des mots qu'on entend depuis 2014
la dmr poutine a toujours démenti être
intervenu dans le conflit en ukraine de
l'est alors qu'on savait très bien que
c'était son armée ses généraux et son
pays qui étaient à la manoeuvre pour
créer et diriger ces républiques
séparatistes
autoproclamé de donetsk de lougansk mes
plats d'hiver poutine étant un chef
d'état on doit donner la version
officielle des faits si on veut
respecter la neutralité et donc il
fallait toujours prendre des précautions
parce que c'était parole contre parole
aujourd'hui cette histoire s'effondre
comme un château de cartes mais le
problème c'est que en russie la
propagande elle continue à être pleine
et entière est encore plus son temps de
guerre la propagande elle monte en
intensité alors les esprits sont
échaudés ici c'est ce qu'on remarque
d'un côté il ya des gens qui commencent
à trembler à avoir peur parce qu'ils se
rendent compte de ce qu'est en train de
faire la russie et de ce qu'est en train
de faire de la dîmière poutine ceux là
ont peur de parler il ya beaucoup de
gens qui ont refusé de répondre à mes
questions dans la rue et puis en face il
ya ceux qui au contraire deviennent
extrêmement agressif en dix ans
anti-occidentaux je suis une
représentante d'une chaîne de télévision
française donc pour eux je suis la
représentante de l'état français donc
pour eux je porte la voix occidentale
donc pour eux je veux attaquer la russie
alors je me fais traiter de traître par
exemple ça c'est quelque chose qui
apparaît qu'on avait vu des gens en
crimée au moment des événements parce
qu'il ya cette propagande derrière qui
échauffe les esprits qui qui qui mène à
l'agressivité et le problème c'est que
la liberté d'expression étant totalement
ou près anéantie en russie durant ces
dernières années au fur et à mesure et
bien vous lisiez avec ces arrestations
de personnes qui essayent de manifester
leur opposition à cette guerre et qui se
fond qui se font arrêter toute
manifestation publique par ailleurs
étant interdite eh bien on risque tout
simplement de finir avec un pays qui
devra vivre sous ce joug qui devrait
vivre sous le sceau de ceux de 7,2 cette
fausse histoire de ce qu'est la guerre
en ukraine et pire encore si vladimir
poutine occupe l'ukraine et si ils
instaurent là bas cette version de
l'histoire et condamne parce que
vladimir poutine a dit qu'il voulait
mener des procès contre ceux contre tout
ce qu'il jugeait coupable de crime or on
sait ce qui s'est passé dans la
république séparatiste de données est ce
qui est de lougansk arrestations
arbitraires exécutions arbitraires au
tout début
tortures emprisonnements donc vraiment
il est à craindre que que le scénario en
ukraine si occupations il y à part la
russie et bien ce soit extrêmement
difficile avec notamment des millions de
personnes qui seront obligés de fuir non
pas parce qu'elles feront des combats
mais parce qu'elle ne voudront pas vivre
sous le joug de vladimir poutine
merci beaucoup il est l'âme volochine
mobiliser au plus près